so something called esg is one of the
operating principles of global investing
right now but try to get someone to
define with precision what esg is and no
one will because there is no precise
definition because the point of it
is to push
corporate investors to the left and then
of course to punish anyone who descends
in pursuit of high esg scores poor
countries like sri lanka have destroyed
their economies and then saw their
government toppled as a result countries
like germany are dimming their traffic
lights to save electricity because ef
gsg
so if esg
accelerates in this country you can
imagine where we will be
very few politicians seem aware this is
even happening one who does know what's
going on is doing something to stop it
is the governor of florida ron desantis
he has an announcement tonight about his
plan to fight esg in the state of
florida governor desantis joins us now
governor thanks so much for coming on
and thanks for noticing this it's a big
deal
so what are you going to do to push back
well tucker we're going to do a couple
things first we are going to do through
florida state pension system a flat ban
on any type of esg and as you say they
like to wiggle around it's basically a
way for them to do politics
so we're going to make sure that that
fiduciary duty is defined very clearly
and that they stick to that we're also
want to provide protections for people
in the financial marketplace from being
discriminated against based on ideology
i mean we've seen wall street banks
discriminate against contractors who are
involved in helping us against illegal
immigration or against firearm
manufacturers things they don't like so
the upshot of all this tucker is we want
to stop these kind of masters of the
universe from trying to do through
economic power what they cannot achieve
at the ballot box and it's really an end
run around democracy where they're
trying to impose these things and here
in florida i want to be governed by the
values of destin not the values of davos
well that's exactly right it's
anti-democratic i mean so no nobody ever
votes on i mean there's never been a
vote on anything
pertaining to
to esg am i right
that's right and what happens is you'll
have asset managers who manage all these
pension funds you know they will require
esg the companies themselves will do it
i think there's a couple reasons i mean
i do think part of this is there's woke
employees in these companies and the
inmates have basically run the asylum so
the so some of the ceos been to that but
i do think there are some of these ceos
tucker who really like to exert power
over the rest of us and that's what
we're doing it'll be a disaster for our
economy
of course with what we've seen with the
energy but to have the economy
politicized this way that's a recipe for
disaster but then also it takes power
away from the american people and lodges
it into these international corporate
titans
and that's not i think what our founding
fathers ever intended
it certainly isn't and it's been going
on for years and i don't think i've ever
heard a national level politician
mention it even mention it are other
governors where this is happening in
their states with their state's pension
funds
i think there i think there are and i
think that you're going to see some
other states uh do what florida then
what i'd like to do
is get a lot of the conservative states
together and let's get our proxy voting
rights on on all of our funds let's
combine those and vote as a block tucker
we'd have over a trillion dollars in
assets between just the red states that
would make a difference when you're
talking about that so we would be able
to check
a lot of these esg votes that are going
on throughout corporate america so i
would urge all my fellow governors
around the country hell republican or
democrat you know let's band together
and let's fight back against this so we
can keep power to the people
yeah because the the consequences we've
seen around the world have been really
really severe governor rhonda sanders
the floor i appreciate your telling us
about that thanks very much
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight